here's what would happen if the Mulla  Perrier Dam suddenly collapsed  this enormous Dam in Kerala India has  held strong since 1895 but it's in an  earthquake zone and full of cracks if a  crack expanded all the way to the Damned  Reservoir the dam would burst you'd be  in deep trouble very deep as the dirty  water filled with soil and rocks float  out faster and faster with the brake  you'd have enough water to fill 180  000 Olympic-sized swimming pools  buildings roads and bridges will be  wiped out after 45 minutes flooding  would reach the nearby ducky Dam if the  pressure was strong enough 15 dams  leading to the Arabian Sea could fall  the lives of three and a half million  people would be devastated it would cost  billions of dollars to rebuild the dam  so